>> Sydney Trent: -- Sydney
Trent, Social Issues Editor
at the Washington Post
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First a word of thanks to the
Co-Chairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein, and the other
generous sponsors who've made
this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for questions.
And I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you will
be included in the videotape
of this event which
may broadcast later.
I'm happy to introduce you today
young adult fiction author,
David Levithan.
David has been a pioneer
in expanding the role
of gay characters
in teen literature.
His first novel, Boy Meets Boy
, started as a story he wrote
for friends for Valentine's Day.
His other acclaimed
fiction includes Every Day,
Another Day, and
Two Boys Kissing.
His best-selling
collaborations include Nick
and Norah's Infinite Playlist
written with Rachel Cohn,
and Will Grayson, Will Grayson
written with John Green.
His latest novel is Sam
and Ilsa's Last Hurrah also
written with Rachel Cohn.
In 2016, David was
named the recipient
of the Margaret A. Edward's
Award for his contribution
to young adult literature.
His forthcoming book for
young adults is Someday.
When not writing during
spare hours on weekends,
Levithan is Editorial
Director at Scholastic
and the founding editor of The
Push and Print which is devoted
to finding new voices and new
authors in teen literature.
And here he is.
[ Applause ]
>> David Levithan:
Hello, everybody.
All right.
So, first things first.
So, I apologize if you've
never seen me speak before,
this is Ninja.
He always takes a
picture with the audience.
It's good.
My family is sitting
in the front
so they'll get to
be in the picture.
All right.
Don't try to upstage Ninja.
That always goes badly.
All right.
And we'll do this, okay.
Now the business is
done, we can begin.
So, thank you for
coming out here
to hear me talk for
a little bit.
I like the Q & A part
better than just me talking,
so I'll try to get through
this part fairly quickly
and hopefully you guys will be
thinking of lots of Qs for me
to A, or else it will be
horribly awkward for us all.
I'm going to talk very
briefly about collaboration.
Of the many things I do as
a writer and as an editor,
collaboration is really one
of the things I love
to do the most.
And the two new books that
I have are collaborations
in very different ways.
Man, I was so excited
that I wasn't up there,
and now there's just
me gesturing behind me.
So my most recent book
that is actually out
and in stores is Sam
and Ilsa's Last Hurrah.
It is a book -- the fifth book
that I wrote with Rachel Cohn.
And just very briefly,
how Rachel
and I do it is we come
up with a premise.
So for this one it was
toxic dinner party.
The idea was it's twins, Sam
and Ilsa, brother and sister,
they are about to
graduate from high school
and they are having
their last dinner party
and they're each allowed
to invite three people,
but the other one is not
allowed to know who is coming.
So, you can imagine this set
up is exactly how it
was writing the book.
That Rachel had her character
and she was inviting her three
characters that I didn't know
about and I had my character
and I was inviting three people
that Rachel didn't know about.
We never plot out our
books ahead of time.
We live them alongside
the characters.
Whatever happens just happens
and we pass chapters
back and forth.
So, for this one I would write a
Sam chapter, email it to Rachel.
She'd write an Ilsa
chapter, email it back to me.
We never talk about it.
We never can sort of
say, why did you do that?
Let's change it.
We just run with whatever
the other person does.
We are such good friends
and have collaborated,
again for five books now, that
we know each other's tricks
and so now we're trying to
do tricks on top of tricks.
So -- so I just wanted to
give you an illustration
of how this works.
So, the first passage, I'm
sure much to Rachel's chagrin,
I'm going to read
is from her chapter.
So this is her first chapter
and this is her introducing
the people who are going
to be attending as
Ilsa's guests.
One of them it's this.
Frederick Polanski, aka
Freddy, the wildcard.
He's an exchange student from
Poland living with a family
on the upper eastside.
I met him when I was with my
best friend watching hot guys
play basketball in Central Park.
Tall, blonde, muscled, deep
blue eyes, uncomplicated.
I'm pretty sure Freckle
-- Franky's --
sorry, Freddy's the guy
I've been looking for,
the one who will break
my brother's heart.
All right.
Challenge laid down.
So I'm giving -- I'm given
this character and then I have
to then introduce
this character.
So, think about the
paragraph that Rachel --
that's all we know about Freddy.
So, what are the obvious
ways to go with that?
Where would you run with that?
Now, you will get the answer
to where I ran with this.
So this is two chapters later,
or three chapters later.
The doorbell rings.
I figure it's going to be Jason,
but when I open the door --
there's no light up
here for me to read by.
It's really amusing.
I find someone who is
not even remotely Jason.
On the hotness scale, Jason
may have been a firecracker,
but this guy is the sun.
He is wearing clothes, but
my body reacts like he isn't.
My gaze rises from his strong
shoulders to focus on his face.
Hello, I say.
And it sounds like hell
because the O comes out too low.
So I did it wrong.
It's Hell-oh.
I see he has one of our
invitations in his hand.
This has to be one
of Ilsa's guests.
Then his other hand
gets my attention
because it has a sock on it.
A white tube sock with
green button eyes,
and a red marker mouth.
And brown yarn hair.
I hope we're in the right
place, the sock says.
It has a disturbingly
attractive voice,
English as a second language
with sexy-beast being the first.
Excuse me?
I say. Because nine out of 10
times when you're confronted
with a sock puppet that is
the only valid response.
This is Ilsa's party, isn't
it, the sock continues.
I look up at the godlike guy
and his lips aren't moving.
It is Ilsa's party, I say.
I am not talking to the hand.
I am talking to the hot
guy who is looking at me
like his hand isn't
talking to me.
I'm her brother, Sam.
Nice to meet you, the sock says.
It holds out its hand which
is his pinky under a sock.
I look at the guy as if to
say, you can't be serious.
And he looks back at me as if
to say, this is my life choice
and you must respect it.
I shake the sock's hand-pinky.
I'm Caspian, it says.
This is Frederick.
He met Ilsa when he
was playing basketball.
I'm not allowed to
accompany him on the court
so I missed the chance
to meet her.
But I'm very happy
to meet you now.
Come in, I say.
Please. Collaboration,
isn't it great?
[ Applause ]
So that is how we work.
If she sends me a hot
guy, I add a sock puppet.
And vice-versa.
And really, the joy of
writing with somebody else is
that you are living the
story alongside them
and you don't know
where it's going to go.
And you're kind of,
in a way, as oblivious
as your characters are.
As with Nick and Norah's
Infinite Playlist ,
our first book together, and
all the ones that have come
after it is about the adventure
of meeting people and sort
of trying to navigate life
through the people
you connect with.
So, the other book, and this
is the first time I'm talking
about it with it coming out in a
month and a day, is Someday ,
which is the third book in sort
of the sequence that started
with my book Every Day
which was turned into a movie
that was released this spring.
So, I wrote Every Day .
It is, if you're not familiar
with it, shame on you.
No, if you are not familiar with
it, it's about somebody named A
who changes bodies every
day and lives every day.
And lives like this
-- has been like this
since birth, and
lives like this.
Not really connecting to anybody
until in their 16th year they
meet somebody named Rhiannon
and fall in love.
And not just fall in love,
but connect with somebody
for the first time.
And so, the book Every
Day is about identity.
It's about who would you be
if you weren't defined
by your body?
If you weren't seen and
defined by gender, by race,
by parentage, by
any outward feature.
If you were just yourself.
Whatever that is.
Often we find there's a
disconnect to who we feel we are
and what our body looks
like, and especially
to how it is interpreted by
other people looking at us.
And so I wanted to talk about
that and write about somebody
who was purely a self and
how they navigate life.
I was that -- I did not think
I would write necessarily more,
but in writing that story I was
curious about Rhiannon's point
of view and my book, Another
Day , is from her point of view
with the same circumstances.
And that book is about love.
And it is about if you say,
oh, I love the you inside,
it doesn't matter
what you look like.
Is that true?
And we say, Love conquers all,
but society does give us certain
pressures and can love conquer
that and how do you
navigate that?
So that's what Another
Day is about.
So this book, Some Day, this
is the Australian edition,
but it's the same cover, so
at least it gives you a sense
of what it will look like when
it comes out on October 2nd,
is the culmination
of all these strands.
In Every Day, it is not
giving away too much to say
that we meet somebody who in
Every Day is in the body
of a reverend named
Reverend Poole.
But it is somebody, who
like A, can change bodies.
Not necessarily every day, but
just jumps from body to body.
And what this third
book is about is
about choices and moral choices.
And the fact that
we can get away
with something doesn't mean
we should necessarily do it.
So, if A is very, what I would
call moral in that when A is
in a body, A does not
want to steer it astray.
Does not want to
take advantage of it.
Does not want to do anything.
The character, who we will call
X, inside Reverend Poole's body
in the first book and
in many different bodies
in this new book,
is the opposite.
It's like hey, nobody
can catch me.
I can get away with anything.
I can manipulate
whatever I want.
I can choose who to be
and I want to be powerful
and I want to be privileged.
And that creates some
conflict to say the least.
It is about these two
world views colliding
and trying to navigate that.
It is told from at least -- I'll
say at least four perspectives.
Part of the hopefully
interesting part
of the book is you never
quite know who is going
to be narrating the
next chapter.
But it really is told from
Rhiannon's point of view,
Nathan who is in the first
book and in the second book, A,
and then this character, X. so
just to dip into a little bit
of evil, I will read a
little bit from X's portion
and then a little
bit from A's portion.
So, this is X. To
stay in a body,
you must take that body over.
To take a body over, you
must kill the person inside.
It is not an easy thing to
do to assert your own self
over the will that
exists in the body.
To smother it until
it is no longer there.
But it can be done.
Not a person you'd
want inside your body.
Meanwhile, A -- it's hard
to talk about this book
without giving the ending
of the other book away,
but A is a little bit
lost and is thinking
that A can be separate
again, but is not and says,
Life is harder when you
have someone to miss.
I wake up in a suburb of Denver
and feel like I am living
in a suburb of my own life.
The alarm goes off
and I want to sleep,
but I have a responsibility,
an obligation.
So I get out of bed.
I figure out I'm in
the body and the life
of a girl named Danielle.
I get dressed.
I try to avoid imagining what
Rhiannon is doing two hours
time difference.
Two hours and a world away.
As you can imagine, if this
book is to have a plot,
A does not stay far
away for very long.
And so, I did say this
is a collaboration
and it was interesting
because there --
there have been eight years
since I wrote the first book.
And there was a movie
that came out.
And it was really
interesting to see
that this book is very much
a response to many things.
I'm collaborating with myself
in that I laid something down
and now I'm pulling
from it again.
I'm collaborating with a
different interpretation.
I loved the movie version
of Every Day unabashedly.
And I -- there are parts of it
that I think actually
improved the book
that I wish I had
put in the book.
And so it was interesting
to have that tone
and have those actors in
my mind as I was writing,
or finishing up this book.
But also it was I've had
so many conversations
about Every Day
and about the fact
that we shouldn't be
defined by our bodies.
That gender is absolutely
not binary
and that you should be able to
choose whatever gender you want.
And about the fact that we
often times subjugate our own
definitions of self because
of the way other people see us
and how we have to
fight back against that
on many different levels.
And so, all of that, as well as
the current political climate
where making moral choices is
more important now than ever,
that all came into this book
which is why it's longer
than the other two books.
So, as promised that it
-- that's my overview.
Now is the awkward
period where I'm like oh,
let's open up to questions and
nobody necessarily has gotten
to the mics yet, people
might be hesitant.
It's great because I'm blind
right now, so I can't even tell
if there's somebody at the mics.
And so if it looks like
I'm gauzily out there,
is there anybody at the -- okay.
People are going.
That's good.
That's promising.
I can see people moving.
There's movement.
That's awesome.
So, yeah. Usually it's
awkward, nobody wants
to ask the first question and --
>> Are there two mics?
>> David Levithan:
Are there two mics?
All right.
So we're going to try to get
through as many questions
as possible.
There is nothing worse
than the author who's like,
I love questions,
then gets one question
and gives a 20 minute answer.
So, we are going to start
with the blur over here.
>> Thank you.
I'll keep it nice and objective.
How many drafts do
you usually go
for before you send a
book off to publishers?
>> David Levithan:
I'm actually --
my writing process is very crazy
in that I will write and rewrite
and rewrite and rewrite
the first three chapters
because I need the
foundation for my book.
So I -- that -- those chapters
will go through 20 drafts
at least, but then once I get
momentum and once I'm moving,
with this -- with the
latest book, Some Day,
MI'd read the first three
chapters about 20 times.
I'd read the first
half of the book twice.
And then I'd only actually
read over the entirety
of the book once before
I sent it to my editor.
And I do send it to my editor
fairly early in the process
because I want to have
that conversation with her.
But usually for me it is focus
on what you want this book
to be, who the characters are,
what it's going to sound like,
and then once you've fixed that
into place then just run with it
and don't go back and
don't draft and redraft
until you have something
that's done.
But that's just me.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: All right.
Over here.
>> I was wondering if you could
speak about how much influence,
or like if you had any
say in like production
and stuff for the movie.
>> David Levithan: I had no --
nothing whatsoever
to do with the movie.
I was extraordinarily lucky
because they actually
hired Jessie Andrews,
who is an amazing
Y-author in his own right,
to write the screenplay.
So I was like, cool.
Ask my friend to
write the screenplay.
That works well.
And he just knew the rhythms.
His -- both his book and his
movie adaptation of his own book
for Me and Earl and
the Dying Girl is one
of my favorite movies
of all time and one
of the best adaptations
I've ever seen.
So I was like if he could
actually adapt his own book,
he could do it for me.
But really I let them do
what they wanted to do.
I did get to sort
of talk to him,
and there were a few things.
He's like how about this?
And I was like I
don't know about that.
And I did get to see a rough cut
of the movie and give comments.
And there was one thing
that was in the movie
that I didn't want
to be in there.
And they actually did take
it out, so that's the extent
of the involvement that I had.
But most of the time
I'm of the --
the mind that the exciting
part is you're giving the story
to somebody else and
seeing what they do with it.
And so far, I've been lucky
that every adaptation I've
had has brought something new
to it that I've liked.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thank you.
All right.
Over here.
>> Hello.
>> David Levithan: Hi.
>> What gave you the original
idea for like A, like this being
that doesn't have any gender
or any binary-ness, I guess?
>> David Levithan: Yes.
I would love -- somebody
once asked that question
in the form of, is this
based on your real life?
And I was like, No.
No. It is not.
So -- so it's not
autobiographical.
But no, really, I wish there
was a better origin story.
Other books of mine have so
much better origin stories.
But this one, I was just
walking to work one day,
feeling whatever I was
feeling about my own body,
and I thought woah,
what would it be
like to switch bodies every day.
What would you --
who would you be
if you were never
in one set body?
And it was just that --
that thought and that
premise that A was born from.
I did not understand any
of the implications of what
that would mean for A until
I started writing the book.
And really, I wrote the
book to answer the question
of who would you be if you
weren't defined by your body?
But the spark was
just that premise.
That question to
myself of what --
what would life be like if
you weren't judging me based
on what you're seeing right now.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thanks.
Over there.
>> Hi. So, I am a special
education literacy teacher
at a middle school here in DC.
>> David Levithan: Awesome.
>> And I'm constantly
just -- like so grateful.
Even as a young teacher I've
seen the growth from when I was
in middle school to now in
how much diversity there is
in the books that are easily
accessible to my kids.
So my question there is really,
what areas do you think
we've done a really great job
in expanding the
kinds of characters?
And why A?
And what areas do you still
see the biggest gaps in?
>> David Levithan: Oh.
I mean, I think there's still
so much work to be done,
although it is incredible
to see how far we've come.
If you, I'm sure look at
the schedule for the first
of these festivals and
the schedule for now,
you will see a much
wider, more diverse range
because that's what
publishing has done.
That's not about the festival.
It's about publishing
in general.
I think really, it's
about intersectionality.
It is about talking about
all the different experiences
within one group.
So, yes, it is great we
have so many queer novels,
but so many of those
queer novels still are
about white, middleclass Simons.
And I love white, middleclass
Simons, and let's face it,
in the movie, Simon's
actually upper-class, but --
but -- which is great.
I mean I was one of those boys.
Like absolutely, but we
actually absolutely have to see
so many other experiences
that are queer experiences.
And there are so many
exciting writers right now
who are writing into that space.
At Scholastic, it's
not a book I edited,
but we published a book
called Hurricane Child,
Mfor middle grade, that is
this amazing queer novel
by Kheryn Callender who has
a YA coming out this fall.
And just there're all these new
writers and new voices coming
out that I think are
going to continue to say,
there is no such thing
as one queer identity,
or one black identity, or one --
just any, any identity
you choose,
there are so many
different perspectives
within that identity and we have
to publish and reflect as many
of those experiences as we can.
So, thanks.
All right.
Over here.
>> Hi. I just wanted to say
that I really loved
Realm of Possibility --
>> David Levithan:
Oh, thank you.
>> -- and I was wondering
kind of how you managed
to get all those characters that
were so interesting and how you
like figured out how they
each kind of were written?
Because they had like prose and
it was different and I loved it.
>> Well, thank you.
So, Realm of Possibility
was my second book.
It is my only book that
is entirely in poetry.
Including some prose pawns,
but it is told from the point
of view of 20 different kids who
all go to the same high school.
And that, honestly, I just made
it up as I went along and played
with the different characters
and didn't start piecing
together how they were connected
until about halfway through.
I just wanted to see which
voices would come up.
And the poetry forms really
led me very well to the voices.
I started that, honestly,
because as an editor I
was editing different
poetry memoirs.
A book by my best
friend, Billy Merrell,
called Talking in the Dark.
A book called You Remind Me
of You by Eireann Corrigan
for the Push and Print
that Sydney mentioned.
And so, I was so drenched in
poetry as a reader and an editor
that just it started to
express itself in my work.
And also it was my second book
and I'd written this really
to be happier, romantic comedy
about two gay boys
called Boy Meets Boy.
And so I wanted my second book
to be as different from that
in form as possible
just to prove
that I could write
different things.
And so writing 20 different
voices in verse was how it went.
But really, for me, my writing,
mine works by just
seeing what comes out
and then forming it
rather than thinking
about it and planning it out.
So for that one the
voices just came to me
and I figured out
how they fit in.
But I'm so glad --
>> Awesome, thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thanks.
All right.
Over there.
>> Hi. One of the books of yours
that I really loved was
Will Grayson, Will Grayson.
And I was -- and
that meant a lot --
that book meant a lot to me,
so I was kind of just wondering
like what the core of
that story was to you.
Like if you had to sum it up,
what do you think was the
most important part of it?
>> David Levithan: I mean --
I mean it's called Will
Grayson, Will Grayson.
If you've not read it,
it's about two boys
with the same name.
One of them was written
by John Green, one by me.
And I think because it was based
on the fact that when I was
in college, there
was a kid walking
around named David Levinthall
and we would be mistaken
for each other.
And so I always thought
that was interesting zoom
into your own identity when
there is somebody who is
like you, even in something
as superficial as
your name, around.
And so, John and I really
wanted to explore that.
And about sort of
what makes you tick.
For my Will Grayson,
it's very much
about making it through
the middle.
That he knows he's gay, but he
doesn't really feel he needs
to like come out in a huge way.
So he's okay with it, but
he just doesn't want anyone
to bother him about it.
He is dealing with his
depression and is on medication
and it's working, but it
is something he still has
to navigate.
But it's not about
him finding out.
It's about him navigating.
So, for me it's about
that state.
It's about when you know what's
going on and you're managing,
and you're dealing with it,
and you're getting through it.
And you meet the people
you need to meet in order
to help you get through it.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thank you.
>> Hi. I wondered if
you could talk more
about gender in your writing.
I know you said Every Day
was not an autobiographical,
but you still had to write
a lot of different genders.
And I noticed in Sam
and Ilsa's Last Hurrah,
Myou're writing Sam who's a boy.
So how would you --
or I assume is a boy.
So, how would you
write someone --
do you have a lot of
experience with writing people
of different genders and how
do you manage writing people
of different genders and
like figuring that out
when it's a different
experience than yours?
>> David Levithan: I
mean, I think it is --
I mean there are
three answers here.
I mean, certainly writing from
the point of view of a gay male,
that is who I am, so
that's easy to do.
Pieces of me come in,
but pieces of me come
in in the other ways too.
With A, it's writing
about somebody
who isn't defined by gender.
And who's never been
defined by gender.
And that, obviously you need
that supernatural conceit
to get to that person.
And that really was thinking
a lot about non-binary.
Thinking a lot about
trans issues and talking
to my friends who
identify as both.
And also just again, thinking
theoretically about it as well.
When I do write from a female
point of view, like Rhiannon
from Another Day, or sometimes
with the books with Rachel,
we will take each
other's characters.
So in Naomi and Ely's
No Kiss List, Naomi.
Again, I feel that hopefully
I've been paying enough
attention to the
females in my life
that I understand a little
bit where they're coming from.
But I'm also very
confident in that I know
that my female editor or
my female co-author will,
if I get something
wrong, tell me, dude,
you got something wrong.
And then we will fix it.
So, I think you absolutely
should write outside your own
voice, but you should
always do your research
and always do it respectfully,
and there should always
be a reason you've chosen
to do it that way.
And that's, with my
writing, what I try to do.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thank you.
>> Hi. So, I know you
said that you love
to collaborate on
different works.
Do you -- how do you choose who
you want to collaborate with,
or do they come to you?
>> David Levithan: I mean, it --
it all happened sort of the
universe just throws it our way.
With Rachel, it was she
had tried to write a novel
that had a he said and she
said, and she tried to do both.
And she was like, I don't --
I want to actually write
with a male writer
doing the he said part.
And I was luckily the best
male writer friend she had,
and I said yes.
With John, it was just I
really loved his books.
He loved my books.
I was like, I have
this crazy idea.
And we ran with it.
With Andrea Cremer, who I
wrote Invisibility with,
we were actually doing an event
with John the first
time we had met.
By the 15th minute of our event
I was singing You've Lost
That Loving Feeling
to her on the stage
which is usually a good sign
that you're getting along.
And that night, jokingly,
she blogged and said,
when is David Levithan
going to write a book --
whatever, with me about
something supernatural?
And I was like Aha!
And I wrote the first chapter
of a book about an invisible boy
and emailed it to her
out of the blue being
like all right, gauntlet thrown.
You're on.
And so that's how that happened.
Don't -- don't go
home and blog now.
That -- that's been done.
But yeah, it's just random
things bring people together.
Nina Lacour, who I wrote
You Know Me Well with,
deliberately we were
saying how we don't
like how queer books
are often separated
into like the lesbian section
and the gay boy section.
It's much more nuanced
and complicated than that.
And so, I was like let's write
a back and forth about --
about a lesbian girl and a
gay boy, obviously not falling
in love with each other,
and like let's play
around with this.
Let's do a romantic comedy where
the two leads are not going
to end up together for very good
reasons and really write a book
that is as queer as it can be
from as many queer
perspectives as possible.
So sometimes there's
a reason for that too.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thank you.
Yes.
>> Okay, so I have
two questions.
Do you want one that's
slightly less complicated,
or a complicated one?
>> David Levithan: We
have little time left,
so let's go for the
slightly less complicated.
>> Do you have any advice
for young writers who want
to write more diverse than
what they usually read?
>> David Levithan: I mean,
I think it is try to have
as diverse a life
as possible and draw
from as many experiences
as you can get.
That -- that nobody is
going to write effectively
from other points of view if
they only know people who are
like themselves and only
interact with people
who are like themselves.
And you have to be
out in the world
and pay attention respectfully.
You're not meeting people just
so you can use their stories.
You are meeting people hopefully
to understand their stories more
and share that experience more.
And so I think it is just
challenging yourself and to push
and also to find the
things you have in common.
It is always -- I can find
something massively in common
with a character who
changes bodies every day
because I also have feelings
of why am I being defined
by who I am on the outside?
Why am I not being seen
by who I am on the inside?
So that's somebody I'm not, but
it's somebody I can connect to.
And I think to effectively
write, you always have
to have a connection
to the characters.
Whether it is through your
own experience or it is
through people that
you know and love.
So that -- that would
be my advice.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: Thank you.
All right.
Over here.
>> Hi.
>> David Levithan: Hello.
>> I'm a little too
short for the mic,
so I'm going to have to tip-toe.
But I'm a second-year student
and I go to school here in DC
and I'm taking this
class on writing culture.
And my professor discussed this
book called And Tango Makes
Three, which is a
children's picture book.
It's about two gay penguins
and they adopt an egg.
It's really cute.
Everyone should read it.
But -- but then we were
discussing this idea
of censorship, and agency, and
morality, and like who gets
to have their say in what
gets to be put in bookshelves
in our classes, in
our libraries,
you know, and all of that.
So, how do you respond to that
as a writer because I know some
of your books have been
on the challenged booklist
and what does that
make you feel?
Or like what do you think
is the purpose of libraries?
Like should they be
acting as moral compasses
or like is it just enough
for them to just be a place
of like information
dissemination?
I'm sorry, that was a lot.
>> David Levithan: No, no.
I mean, I think --
I think a library
and a school library
always have responsibilities
to reflect the world
and everybody in it.
And that's every
viewpoint, everybody in it.
And we certainly can
discuss what is in there,
but they have a moral obligation
to really represent
both the people who are
in their communities,
but also people
who are not in their
communities.
And so, I think that
Tango Makes Three is a
great example.
Where it is about, it's a true
story of these two male penguins
who raised this baby
penguin, but it has been
on the banned books list on
and off for about 20 years.
And it is the classic case,
as with most censorship,
where the people attacking the
book are really attacking the
thing behind the book.
In this case, the fact that we
gay people exist in the world.
And they are under the
misbegotten belief, A,
that if they get
rid of the book,
suddenly we'll just go away.
But then also the fact
that if they attack a book,
a book can't defend itself.
The really great
news is that 97 times
out of 100 the book does defend
itself and stays on the shelves.
That although we do have a
culture of book challenges here
in America that is unlike
anywhere else in the world,
we also have a massive success
rate of people defending books.
So if you think that
by taking that book
about the gay penguins
off the shelves,
the community will
just ignore the fact
that there are gay
people around,
instead it actually
causes people
to defend the book,
defend the identity.
And also have the conversation
that the people who tried
to ban the book wanted to
avoid in the first place.
So, I like that the
system works that way.
>> Thank you.
>> David Levithan: All right.
We have two minutes,
so very quickly.
Rapid fire.
>> Okay, I'm going to
preface this by saying I tried
to get my sister to ask this
question, she didn't want to.
I'm being bribed to ask this.
>> David Levithan: Okay.
>> What, in your opinion, is
the scariest sea creature?
>> David Levithan:
I have no idea,
but after hearing Alex Bracken,
I'm really scared of scorpions.
And that's all I can say.
All right, next question.
>> Yeah, well, this one sort
of piggybacks off of it,
but what were -- when did you
get Boy Meets Boy published?
>> David Levithan:
It was 15 years ago.
>> Okay, yeah.
And considering how long
ago that was, I mean,
what were the challenges of
trying to find a publisher
because I know even, you know,
especially back then and even
to a certain extent today,
there's a certain, you know,
a certain amount of
people who still believe
that LGBT stuff is adult.
Even if there's no
actual, you know,
sexual activity or anything.
Even if it's just these two
people are in a relationship.
So what were the challenges
of getting it published?
>> David Levithan: Well, the
good news is that almost none
of those people work
for publishers.
Publishers -- no,
and I work for one.
Random House was -- it was the
first queer young adult book
that they had published.
Random House Children's Book.
But they were like gung-ho.
They were like, it's about time.
Let's do this.
And certainly there were
gay books before mine
that led the way.
There are gay books after
mine that carried it on.
We are in a beautiful continuum.
And so, -- so I think that
you should never be hesitant
about writing for queer
identities because that --
those are the people who are
out there and that is the books
that publishers want to find.
And again, want to
find as many variations
of the story as possible.
All right.
I think we have time
for one more.
Very quickly.
>> Yeah, so -- I've
been like literally --
like I came here because I
knew you wrote Boy Meets Boy,
Mbut I was like literally --
what I was seeing reading your
stuff about like not being
in the same body all the
time and not being defined
by your body, I was
like literally Googling
like all your books
during the presentation.
And then, what I
found fascinating was
that Every Day and Another
Day were basically the same
book except written
in the point of view
of two different characters.
Like, how did you
decide on that?
>> David Levithan: I mean, very
quickly, it really was I felt
that Rhiannon's voice, although
it came out in the first book,
needed to come out more.
And so, it was going through
everything that had happened
in the first book and just
seeing it through her eyes.
And that's what I wrote down.
>> Oh wow.
>> David Levithan: All right.
We are now out of time,
unfortunately, but I'm signing
from 3:00 to 4:00
downstairs, so please come by.
I'm happy to sign as many books
as you want and to talk to you
and answer any questions
that didn't get to be asked.
Thanks.